bonjour sur cette photo nous avons cinq
jeunes de la caravelle un quartier
sensible du 92 à villeneuve la garenne
qui sont en train de donner un cours à
20 étudiants d' hec
alors comme vous pouvez le constater non
il ne s'agit pas d'un cours de slam
il s'agit d'un cours de langue une
langue qui permet de donner des ordres à
des machines et à des ordinateurs la
langue du 21e siècle
le code informatique et ses jeunes
villeneuve ont été formés par simple au
simplon séné en 2013 d'un constat simple
il ya cinq millions de chômeurs en
france
face à ça des milliers d'opportunités
d'emplois à pourvoir dans le domaine du
développement web et de la programmation
informatique et malgré ça vient le code
ça ne s'apprend toujours pas à l'école
il faut tirer de former et nous ont
servis qu'il n'y avait pas besoin d'être
ingénieur pour être formés aux codes on
a donc imaginé une formation intensive
gratuite par la pratique voire financé
par des bourses
on l'a imaginé gratuite car on la
destine à des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi ou plus globalement à des
profils qui demeurent sous représentées
dans le numérique
la première promotion de simples onians
en septembre 2013
c'était 30 personnes de 18 à 52 ans dont
75 % de demandeurs d'emploi et
bénéficiaires de minima sociaux 50 % de
personnes originaires de quartiers
populaires et 30% de femmes car il ya
encore trop peu développée
quand on a ouvert simplon à montreuil on
nous a dit qu'on n'arriverait pas ce
serait impossible de former des
débutants des non diplômés des
demandeurs d'emploi sur du code mais ces
profils là on les a choisis sans
concession on les a choisis sur la base
de tests qui mettaient à l'épreuve leur
envie et leur motivation car s'il n'a
pas besoin d'être ingénieur en revanche
il faut être déterminés persévérants et
débrouillard ces profils là on les a pas
choisi que sur critères sociaux
on les a choisis parce qu'ils ont toutes
les qualités pour devenir développeur
aujourd'hui simple on accueille sa
deuxième promotion à montreuil roxana
une ancienne élève a ouvert un simple on
en roumanie
rodolphe un ancien élève lui aussi à
former les 15 jeunes de villeneuve la
garenne et hier c'était la première
rentrée dans simplon village à la loupe
dans le perche en zone rurale car sur
ces territoires aussi le numérique peut
devenir un lieu et d'inclusion puissant
en 2015 on est bien parti pour ouvrir
trois autres simples en zone rurale
ainsi qu'à en tunisie et un en afrique
du sud
on nous a dit qu'il serait impossible de
former intensivement gratuitement
surtout des profils atypiques pour le
domaine pourtant les simples oignons
nous ont prouvé le contraire
ils nous ont prouvé qu'on avait bien
fait trois ans leur potentiel et d'aller
chercher des talents là on le voit
souvent que des difficultés on nous a
dit qu'on ne pouvait pas le faire
à ce jour tout ce que nous pouvons
répondre c'est qu'on ne pouvait pas ne
pas le faire merci